esta primera jornada de este largo
proceso debía ser un día muy tranquilo
destinado a que el presidente de la
corte pasara lista a las partes civiles
recordemos que son más de 1800 y a los
14 acusados presentes sin embargo
justamente cuando estaba pasando a lista
los acusados y tocó el turno de sala
gades el único sobreviviente de los
comandos que realizaron los ataques ese
13 de noviembre él comenzó diciendo que
él es el único dios y que mahoma es su
mensajero cuando el juez le preguntó
cuál era su profesión él dijo deje todas
mis profesiones para ser un combatiente
del grupo estado islámico y cuando se le
preguntó el nombre de su madre y su
padre él dijo que no los iba a decir
porque ellos no tienen nada que hacer
aquí esta actitud obviamente afectó
mucho sobre todo a las víctimas que se
encuentran presentes en este proceso
tanto familiares de los fallecidos como
rescatados de los distintos atentados
con los que pudimos conversar en
france24 pero parece que esa la carne de
lan tiene muchas ganas de hablar pues
esta tarde se produjo un receso ya que
uno de los acusados se sintió mal al
volver de esa pausa nuevamente apuntó
con el dedo al presidente de la corte
denunciar que a él lo han tratado estos
últimos seis años dijo como un perro
pero yo no he denunciado nada porque sé
que una vez muerto voy a resucitar el
presidente de la corte tomó algunos
minutos para lograr que se calmara que
volviera a sentarse y le recordó que
este no es un tribunal eclesiástico sino
un tribunal de la república así que esta
primera audiencia que debía ser
tranquila estuvo muy movida nos queda un
largo proceso por delante ustedes lo
saben al menos nueve meses de audiencias